bien
[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros hoy
en 5 minutos con nos acompaña a javier
couso profesor de derecho constitucional
de la universidad diego portales en
chile- y catedrático de la universidad
de utrecht profesor gracias por estar
con nosotros en francés 24 en chile unos
15 millones de personas están
habilitadas para participar en el
plebiscito del 25 de octubre que
decidirá si la constitución de 1980
redactada y aprobada bajo el régimen
militar de augusto pinochet sigue siendo
o no la carta magna de la nación
es por eso profesor que le pregunto cuál
es la importancia de este plebiscito en
el país en un contexto de protestas y
descontento social además le quiero
preguntar que votarían exactamente los
chilenos
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
este domingo y le enfrenta a un proceso
electoral de características históricas
nosotros más allá de una antigua
tradición republicana vivimos hoy día
con una constitución impuesta por la
única dictadura de carácter criminal que
tenía nuestra historia esto es algo que
tuvimos que aceptar porque fue el precio
de la transición o se aceptaba esta
constitución o derechamente era muy
difícil poder iniciar una transición a
la democracia pero esta constitución
tiene demasiados estos neoliberales y
sesgos que hacen muy difícil es hallar
maneras más humanas de pensar la
relación entre el estado de la economía
no estamos hablando de un cambio radical
de una economía de mercado a otra por
ejemplo centralmente planificada
simplemente de dotar de elementos
sociales democráticos a nuestra economía
eso se ha hecho muy difícil por una
constitución que realmente se encuentra
entre las que más
promueve el rol de ley de los privados
en la provisión de servicios públicos
una constitución que le hizo imposible
por ejemplo a la presidenta bachelet
incorporar medidas tan normales como una
mejor protección de los derechos de los
consumidores una mejor protección de los
derechos de los trabajadores entonces
más allá de la parte simbólica el hecho
de esta constitución fue impuesta
fraudulentamente por una dictadura
miliar muy cuenta nos abre la
posibilidad de realmente unirnos
como país alredor de la rotación que
todos podamos sentir que es más si ahora
profesor en caso de que gane el sí para
modificar esa constitución cuáles serían
los pasos a seguir y cuánto duraría y
además cómo sería este proceso para
poder modificarla
es más largo porque este ocurrió en
colombia que tomó cerca de un año este
va a tomar en total dos años porque en
cinco meses más de aprobarse la idea de
la nueva constitución este domingo para
elegir a los constituyentes ellos van a
empezar a trabajar en mayo del 2021 o
nueve meses prorrogables por tres meses
hasta probablemente mayo del año 2022 y
dos meses después en julio del año 2022
habrá otro plebiscito para que el país
diga así les parecería en el texto que
se le ofrece o si más bien prefieren
seguir con el actual
ahora profesores le pregunto vamos a ver
un escenario hipotético de que gane el
no cuáles serían estas consecuencias
para el país socialmente hablando
si prevaleciera el rechazo por supuesto
si su país donde los eventos electorales
se respeta mucho las autoridades
electorales tienen mucha credibilidad
nadie duda del resultado y eso es muy
importante particularmente la región
latinoamericana en ahora incluso en eeuu
donde el propio presidente de trabajo
está poniendo en duda yo creo que no va
haber duda de si se va a respetar el
resultado por supuesto que yo te daría
en ese caso que la gente que ha dicho
rechazo pero quiero reformar que más
bien la derecha no todas pero buena
parte de la derecha chilena
efectivamente cumplen su palabra y se
llame a reformar aquellos aspectos eso
francamente es intolerable para mucha
buena parte de la población muy
rápidamente profesor qué pasa si gales
siga la prueba por supuesto que esto no
va de la noche a la mañana a terminar
con las razones que llevaron al estadio
social de hace un año
sí pero va a hacer un elemento muy
constructivo después de un año muy
controversial muy polarizado yo creo que
esto abre oportunidades que los chilenos
que hemos estado francamente con nuestra
autoestima baja como país porque nos
golpeó mucho el estallido social y luego
de algunos volvió mucho la manera en que
se manejó la pandemia en un primer
momento ahora las cosas están mejor yo
creo que va a ser algo muy positivo para
que el país se reencuentra profesor
gracias por estar con nosotros en
francés de 4 ustedes también gracias por
seguir conectados a nuestra pantalla
[Música]